hello everyone
scp-682 here i feel like playing a game
and nobody's gonna stop me so there we
go that's it
no one explanation needed name six eight
too easy I can do that
all these details don't care start ah so
insight play again because I am lonely
and I see people murdered everyone in
the building so there's only so much
entertainment one we get from our the
genocide
so our decided to seek entertainment
elsewhere
I love another thing I just read my file
the BSC P foundation hassled me and I
would just like to say not fair people
not fair I don't hate everything okay
all my hate is bad fashion sense okay
never mind never mind the game stop it
let's get to it okay ah this is what uh
what does this ah the d-class self
probably this is water ID consult I'd
never seen deke ourselves I just I've
seen them and their insides all over the
floor and in my stomach
and all of my face ahahaha this was
about [ __ ] feminist West
please give you recess
oh you have no idea
you have the serious walk I have ever
seen that I've seen a lot of Saudis in
my time and you are the only soldier
that looks like here's a map between of
his ass
did not work that well he does that they
look like that
Jesus Christ [ __ ] hell
as a doctor all night all night
hahahaha just me dinner
oh say I'm a nice guy under camera they
say about me yes I've been here before
you [ __ ] I've lived for quite a while
Allah it's not necessary I'm gonna go
blab did tours that's what I want logos
on each other how am I supposed to go oh
I see drops haha save me haha
this won't play nothing oh hi guys hey
[ __ ] a free pass this time job Duncan
and then their seconds thanks to our
twice I have carried this ice and my
back
oh yeah then seven three ditching in the
fund he gets on the farm and when I did
I instead of playing the [ __ ] DC day
and an undisclosed location brilliant
I suppose I was picking this up like
that why not why not this place means is
it's scary bus we've left everyone the
only thing I remember I have to come
through here through outside then limits
here I'm at the other side oh let's see
a Dookie boards a little ducky a comedy
I committed adultery what the [ __ ] kind
of game is this
I'm even left the dock here [ __ ] sake
yeah I suppose let's walk through night
or will I say when they kill themselves
when are they ever just going to reach
the stage where they just lay down and
let me eat their brains how long without
me [ __ ] sake I apologize for the
swearing okay
I don't really make a habit of swearing
I just this is ducky there my car gets
oh damn it this is the best room I'm
sitting sitting on right now this is
brilliant
yeah as a waitress ha ha ha ha the side
cup I'm sorry I didn't instruct again
almost it is really almost not to
navigator could not connect to my
database you might give me then twice
oh [ __ ] was that a plane can now log to
the coal and gas mask and I yes Oh
brilliant brilliant nominated now are
this right will [ __ ] won 7-3 [ __ ] you
up you stupid ass [ __ ] this game I am
going
you